I find that the easiest way
to keep things straight,
is to think about this relation
as referring to hardness.
Thus, I would read this as
saying B is as hard as A.
The word reduction also
makes sense in this light.
We are reducing the hardness
of A to that of B.
The answer of course is the first and
the last.
If there's a decider for B then
that let's us build the decider for
A just by composing with the reduction.
And the last statement is just
a counter positive of the first.
The second statement is false because it
might very well be that A is decidable,
but B is not.
A could be easy while B could be hard.
And the same logic applies
to the third state.